i
[Música]
y
en eeuu un promedio de 2,4 millones de
vacunas son administradas al día y según
el presidente yo baiden a este ritmo
todos los adultos estadounidenses
tendrían acceso a una de estas para el
primero de mayo el lunes de esta semana
cerca de 110 millones de dosis se habían
administrado en el país llevando a que
cerca del 22% de la población haya sido
vacunada al menos una vez aunque en su
momento se criticó el desorden del
inicio de la vacunación en la 'operación
works piter liderada por la
administración de donald trump ésta fue
la que ayudó a financiar la producción y
la disponibilidad de las vacunas en
tiempo récord hoy varios republicanos
argumentan que críticas de la
administración de bailén a la de hecho
están politizando y desincentivando que
los simpatizantes de trump que son cerca
de la mitad del país se pongan la vacuna
para lograr la inmunidad de rebaño que
necesita a eeuu para salir de la
pandemia
[Música]
en el estado de nueva york
cerca de 67 millones de dosis hasta el
momento un 22,5 de los neuquinos han
recibido al menos una inyección y cerca
del 11 por ciento ya han recibido la
vacuna completamente a partir de mañana
se aumenta el grupo de personas que
pueden recibir la vacuna llegando a los
12 millones de newyorkinos elegibles
para vacunarse quien se incluirá en este
grupo pues bien todos aquellos
trabajadores que estén de cara al
público como por ejemplo guardias de
seguridad conserjes de los edificios
aquellas personas que trabajan en
edificios gubernamentales o en
organizaciones sin ánimo de lucro el
presidente de eeuu joe biden ha dicho
que quiere que antes del 1 de mayo esté
vacunada toda la población adulta de
eeuu pero aquí en nueva york su
gobernador andrew como considera que
esta hazaña es bastante poco complicada
porque de los 15 millones de adultos
que hay en eeuu hasta el momento sólo se
han vacunado 2 millones continua y
vacunas suficientes para todos
[Música]
la vacunación en florida está yendo
según lo previsto ahora los mayores de
60 años y cualquier persona con
condiciones médicas preexistentes ya son
elegibles para la dosis contra el
coronavirus el gobernador del estado el
republicano ron de santis confía en que
a partir de mayo toda la población pueda
vacunarse sin importar la edad es la
misma previsión que maneja la casa
blanca según anunció el presidente joe
biden hace unos días lo más importante
dicen los expertos sanitarios es que la
vacunación sea accesible por eso las
autoridades están habilitando farmacias
supermercados y grandes superficies
comerciales para convertirlos en grandes
sitios de vacunación de esta manera se
podrá inocular a la mayor parte de la
población en el menor tiempo posible el
objetivo el de siempre terminar con la
crisis cuanto antes y poder volver a una
vida más o menos normal como la que
conocíamos antes de la pandemia aunque
aquí en florida apenas hay restricciones
y el sur del estado se ha convertido en
el paraíso para miles de jóvenes que
vienen a pasar las vacaciones del spring
break lo hacen sin mascarilla y sin
mantener la vista
a social dicen que están confiados
porque ya hay vacuna a pesar de que
muchos aún no la tienen